seriously admitted to the Arab League
after a 12-year absence the decision is
the most significant today to be taken
by Arab states to normalize relations
with Damascus
in this same Hall in 2011 the Arab
League adopted a resolution to suspend
Syria's membership saying Bashar
al-assad's government had failed to stop
its Crackdown on protesters
although little has changed in the Assad
government's approach towards those
opposed to his rule those in favor of
the step say it will have a major impact
on the future of Syria and its neighbors
improved stability in the country is
expected to enable the return of those
who fled its 12-year War
critics say rehabilitating Assad sets a
dangerous precedent for holding power to
account in Syria and around the world
but the Arab League expects the region
to benefit from its decision Regional
moves towards reconciliation started in
the past five years in 2018 the UAE and
Bahrain reopened their embassies in
Damascus and since 2020 Turkish and
Syrian intelligence officials have met
several times recently both countries
Deputy foreign ministers met in Moscow
following talks between defense
ministers in 2022
Saudi foreign minister Faisal bin Farhan
then met Assad nearly three weeks ago
some in the Arab League argue better
Regional relations with Damascus could
limit Iran and Russia's influence yet
the announcement comes just days after
the Iranian president visited Syria
that's relations between Tehran and
Riyadh are also taking a new Direction
Ali Hashem al-jazeera
earlier I spoke to Luis Safi a former
opposition leader in Syria he is his
reaction to the Syrian government's
readmission to the Arab League
I can say this is a sad day for anyone
who cares about democracy the rule of
law and human rights this is
Rehabilitation one of the brutal most
brutal regimes that we know of in
current days so yeah I think the many
syrians will not be happy
and this will not really bring more
peace and stability to Syria
on the contrary probably this would be
very destabilizing but what we're
hearing and there's still a few details
to to get out of what was agreed uh at
the SRB League meeting is that this
would only happen under certain
conditions do you think the Arab League
is capable today of enforcing those
conditions on the Assad regime clearly
Arab League has no power to enforce
anything in Syria
and I didn't really hear conditions to
be honest with you I mean the only
condition I heard that many uh foreign
ministers Arab foreign ministers were
happy to preserve the Arab identity
um but had nothing nothing to say about
preserving human rights the right of
Syrian people
um and to maybe put some pressure on the
regime to change the the their internal
policies you say a sad day for the
Syrian people for the the thousands
hundreds of thousands of victims of this
conflict
where does it leave the Syrian
opposition I know you're no longer
leading the opposition but what would
you advise them to do now
well I think the the serial position
today is not in a position to really uh
do anything to change that that Dynamics
other than
um standing by the the their principles
you know the rights of the people should
come first and it saddes me that to see
that many Arab leaders don't care about
about the the life of of the Arabs that
they they seem to be interested to to
defend their identity but their rights
don't matter
well let's speak to our senior political
analysts about all this Marwan bashara
who's joining us via Skype from Paris
Marwan um as you heard the Syrian
opposition former Syrian opposition
leader there say this is a sad day for
the Syrian people he said they feel
betrayed what do you think first of all
is driving this need to rehabilitate
Bashar Assad
pragmatism some will call it opportunism
but that would say in statecraft that
certainly would be called pragmatism in
the sense that I think Arab leaders have
either sympathized with asset for a long
time like for example the Egyptian
president who took over by a coup d'etat
back in 2013 and it really has been more
or less against the Syrian Revolution
others have already given up on the
entire issue of uh of a change in Syria
back in 2016 2017 like Saudi Arabia
nation of a long process of an admission
and an admission that asset will stay
or for those who supported the Arab
Spring and admission of defeat
because basically the past dozen years
we've seen a full cycle a full circle of
the Arab Spring Rising back in 2011 and
basically eclipsing this week in 2023.
what about countries that supported this
opposition and countries that had
expressed reservations about readmitting
Syria into the Arab League I'm thinking
here of Qatar for example countries like
Morocco which also had reservations
where does this leave them and and you
know their place in the Arab League if
this vote went ahead today with some
country's absent what does it say about
the Dynamics within the organization
well I mean the organization has always
been splits right I mean the biggest
split of all of course happened back
during the invasion of Iraq when the
Arab League was basically split down the
middle uh it was also before that many
years during the Camp David Accords and
so on so forth so the idea that the Arab
countries disagree is actually a healthy
thing it's not a bad thing it's good for
them to be United
and for none of them basically to leave
because of disagreement so I think
Kuwaiti Qatari Moroccan or other
opposition uh to the return of Syria the
way it has been done is a healthy thing
and I think it will maintain that
pressure on other more enthusiastic
members of the Arab look who want to
deal with the regime the bloody regime
in Syria by making sure that the process
the so-called step-by-step or the
transitional process of dealing with the
Assad regime is at its beginning not at
its end in the sense that yes it would
be admitted as of this week but no not
everything is going to happen
automatically meaning the regime in
Syria is going to have to carry a number
of steps take a number of measures based
on a number of
conditions not necessarily preconditions
that will emit the desires of minimum
civil civilizational normality if you
will meaning not to murder kill repress
and so on and so forth and certainly
allow for the millions of refugees and
displaced people to return to their
homes I think this kind of division this
kind of pressure on the other members is
healthy also I think just to quickly to
add that we all know that a lot of Arab
countries want to get in into the Syria
action because Iran is of course also
expanding its influence in Syria 11
years after Tehran has supported the
Assad regime and I think many in the
Arab world not only among the neighbors
like Jordan and others who feel that
Iran might actually establish a major
base expansion in his interest to no
return within the country so they are
rushing to Syria right a lot of
countries I mean in order to balance it
briefly Marwan what about the the West
the U.S for example where are they left
in all this because they also supported
the Syrian opposition
yes I think the United States has
different calculus altogether some of
some of the members like Saudi Arabia
Jordan and others or Egypt who are
really live in proximity to Syria and
some of them like turkey also very
pragmatic towards Syria who have
suffered from the question of
refugees and so forth and violence and
terrorism and so on a lot of these
countries have immediate uh concerns and
really want to get this thing done and
they want to see how instead of fighting
back to basically fight forward when it
comes to Syria and I think after Saudi
Arabia reached the deal of normalization
with Iran basically the nature of the
conflict have changed from that of
strategic tension to diplomatic tensions
so now they're basically competing
diplomatically and I would guess
economically over Syria America has a
different character together America has
not reached or reached a new nuclear
deal with Iran and hence the subject of
Syria remains part of that
iranian-american calculus thank you for
that Maron Bashar our senior political
analysts live there in Paris